de la reine d'Angleterre je salue tous
ceux qui nous rejoignent sur Youtube ce
qui sont qui restent avec nous sur le
Figaro.fr et qui commente je vous
rappelle que la reine d'Angleterre est
décédée elle avait 96 ans après 70 ans
de règne elle c'est donc éteindre tout à
l'heure l'annonce a été donné un peu
avant 20h le prince Charles n'est plus
prince il est roi et il prend le nom de
Charles III le protocole va se
poursuivre la reine d'Angleterre devrait
être enterré dans une dizaine de jours
mais on suivra évidemment tout ça tout
au long des jours à venir cette soirée
spéciale évidemment vous continuez de
réagir je suis avec Pascaline Podevin
alors on peut peut-être rappeler ce qui
s'est passé tout au long de la journée
elle avait une santé défaillante depuis
quelques temps avec un silence total de
Buckingham et là cet après-midi se
communiquer on a senti que c'était un
peu différent ouais on a senti que
c'était différent notamment en raison de
la temporalité et du rythme des
événements d'habitude quand la reine de
quand la reine avait un problème de on
avait des informations distillées au
compte-goutte elle avait passé des
examens elle avait été hospitalisée
souvent on ne savait pas pourquoi
c'était ce qui s'était passé en novembre
quand elle avait dû annuler des
événements très importants et qu'elle
avait été hospitalisée il avait été
question à l'automne d'un mal de dos
aussi mais rien de plus et là hier elle
devait faire une une apparition lors
d'un événement en visio donc même pas
physiquement qu'elle a annulé les
médecins lui avaient recommandé de se
reposer et là on apprend à midi que les
médecins l'ont ausculté ce matin qu'ils
ont trouvé son état préoccupant c'est le
terme qui a été utilisé dans le
communiqué de presse qui est paru ce
midi à 13h30 environ et ensuite tout
s'est accéléré le communiqué de presse
et surtout la famille royale qui est
arrivée à son chevet très très vite ils
ont tous tout lâché pour tout de suite
prendre des avions des voitures pour
ceux qui étaient à côté et arriver à
Balmoral et ça vraiment la famille
royale qui se rassemble autour d'elle
aussi vite ça a été le signe que
que les choses allaient peut-être
se terminer comme elles se sont
terminées le roi Charles devrait prendre
la parole dans la soirée on suivra ça
évidemment parce que ce serait une
annonce très suivie partout dans le
monde on l'imagine vous parlez de sa vie
de famille là avec
cette chape de plomb parfois au-dessus
de la famille royale rien ne filtre
est-ce que au fil du temps et bien on
s'est adapté avec une nouvelle
communication est-ce qu'on a donné plus
de transparence
une transparence toute relative une
transparence contrôlée comme c'est
toujours le cas avec la famille royale
je pense que les nouvelles générations
et surtout ce sera Charles s'y est
adapté un peu et s'y adaptée à forcément
mais c'est surtout on compte surtout sur
les nouvelles générations et sur le
prince William et Kate Middleton
depuis qu'on est ensemble d'abord il y a
un roi là
on l'oublie presque il a même été
question à une époque on se demandait si
elle est même pas indiqué directement il
y a des rumeurs comme ça qui circulaient
parce que il a 73 ans quand même Charles
bien sûr qu'il va être roi bien sûr
qu'il va faire des choses je pense qu'on
ne peut on ne passe pas toute une vie on
sait qu'on va devenir roi pour reculer
au dernier moment bien sûr qu'il va être
roi donc bien sûr il va lui aussi
épouser l'époque épouser la modernité
mais le prince William met son épouse
Kate Middleton eux aussi on doit se
rôles endos ce rôle depuis quelques
années et le fond très très bien et je
pense que ce sont surtout eux qui
aideront la monarchie
le prince le roi Charles c'est dur à
dire c'est difficile de pour les
Français King Charles ça va être plus
facile que le prince le roi Charles
décidément devait vivre encore 30 ans et
bien à nouveau le prince William
deviendrait roi qui a 70 ans oui mais
je pense qu'il occupera une position
peut-être il sera peut-être davantage
présent auprès de son père que Charles a
été auprès de sa mère alors il va
devenir moi il est roi ça y est avec une
reine qui est sa femme mais qui devient
reine
c'était lors des 70 ans je crois du
jubilé Elizabeth avait décerné ce titre
à Camilla comme on peut rappeler leur
histoire d'amour c'est pas si facile
c'est très très compliqué il s'était il
s'était rencontré avant même que Charles
n'épousiana qui est quand même un
mariage plutôt arrangé et leur relation
je crois qu'à l'époque Camilla était
mariée elle-même
donc la relation n'a pas pu aboutir à
cette époque mais ils sont toujours
restés en contact
en contact même rapproché puisque il y
avait clairement comme Diana Lady lors
d'une interview nous étions trois dans
ce mariage ça fait une personne de trop
et elle l'a su on connaît tous les
scandales qui ont lieu mais finalement
après la mort de Diana l'amour a
triompher ils se sont mariés et c'est
elle aujourd'hui qui est à ses côtés
quel sera sa position physique j'ai
envie de dire auprès de Charles lors du
couronnement c'est quelque chose aussi
qu'on attend avec impatience alors
est-ce que vous avez des petites
anecdotes gens parce que je j'ai le
papier là que j'ai imprimé tout à
l'heure l'article d'Adrien jaune c'est
très intéressant qui retrace le parcours
de de la reine alors j'ai vu qu'elle
conduisait mais qu'elle avait pas le
permis de conduire par exemple conduire
elle a pas de passeport non plus parce
que je crois que c'est du parcourir le
monde entier mais ça passeport je pense
qu'elle a pas passé par les mêmes
douanes que nous de toute façon oui oui
je pense que de toute façon ni les mêmes
avions ni les mêmes douanes et je pense
que la personne suffisait on dit un
petit mot parce que je sais que c'est
votre spécialité vous êtes à Madame
Figaro cette série the crown alors
depuis plusieurs années est-ce que cette
série a aidé favoriser populariser la
royauté ou à l'inverse à donner une
mauvaise image non moi je pense que
c'est la popularisé en tout cas pour ce
qui est du personnage d'Elisabeth parce
que the crown notamment dans sa saison 1
s'attachait aux jeunes années d'une
reine qui était interprétées par
clairefeuille magnifiquement bien
d'ailleurs et ça la rendait très
touchante c'est ça paraît mais en même
temps moi je me rappelle de cette scène
peut-être même dans le tout premier
épisode on la voit jeune mariée en
Afrique en train de film d'avoir une
caméra Super 8 en voyage de noces
d'ailleurs peut-être non je sais plus
elle s'est en voyage en Afrique avec
Philippe lui il est allongé sur un lit
nu et elle filme ses fesses comme ça
effectivement ça paraît trivial mais ça
l'est pas et il y avait plein de petites
choses comme ça qui nous la rendaient
très très attachantes je pensais à ça
dans la première saison aussi la
première saison est abondamment revenue
sur sa relation à sa soeur Margaret qui
était beaucoup plus rock n' roll qui
était un personnage aussi beaucoup plus
blessé sur le fait qu'elle est interdit
à ma garde de se déposer l'homme qu'elle
aimait ce qu'il a aussi été quelques
décisions qu'elle a pas dû prendre de
gaieté de coeur bref je pense que la
série en humanisant extrêmement la
rendue très touchante ce qui a pu la
rendre touchante et ce qui a pu
l'humaniser auprès des Français c'est
lorsqu'elle parlait notre langue propose
de regarder ce petit extrait ce
reportage
[Musique]
je suis profondément aimé ainsi que mon
mari de votre généreuse accueil
vos paroles nous ont rappelé à tous deux
des souvenirs qui nous sont chers je
Boisse à la prospérité de la France et
des peuples qui lui sont associés
puissent la confiance et la
compréhension mutuelle entre la
République française et le Royaume-Uni
uni durait toujours
monsieur le Président Madame et Monsieur
je rends hommage à la nation française
je me rappelle le plaisir que j'ai eu à
découvrir ce beau pays pour la première
fois
et à cultiver à mon tour une grande
affection pour le peuple français
ou qu'il soit lorsqu'ils se rencontrent
nous compatriotes retrouvent toujours ce
mélange unique d'amitié de rivalité dans
la bonne humeur ainsi que l'admiration
qui constitue l'essence des liens qui
unissent la Grande-Bretagne et la France
il y a maintenant 50 ans à la veille des
célébrations du centenaire j'ai prié les
Canadiens de continuer à donner
l'exemple en incarnant les valeurs
d'égalité de liberté et d'inclusion
aujourd'hui ces valeurs demeurent dans
l'expérience canadienne
vous former encore un pays jeune mais
vous avez déjà toute la maturité voulue
pour suivre votre vocation
au cours de la prochaine année vous
aurez l'occasion de rappeler au monde
l'importance de préserver ses valeurs et
de les transmettre au futur générations
avec François Hollande il y a une
anecdote autour de ce dîner du foie gras
je sais pas si vous la connaissez et
bien la reine d'Angleterre adorait le
foie gras le prince Charles pas du tout
il vient d'ensemble à Paris et puis dans
le protocole et bien le prince Charles
dit non non pas de foie gras sauf que
sauf que sauf que la reine d'Angleterre
l'a imposé ici moi je veux du foie gras
c'est très français j'adore ça et je
veux manger du foie gras merci beaucoup
parce qu'elle une fois de vendre alors
allez quand même un dernier mot vous me
donnez ce que vous ce dont vous
rappellerez toujours de la reine
d'Angleterre une image une anecdote
dites moi
une image une anecdote
sans doute effectivement celle dont on a
parlé des jeux il y en a plusieurs les
Jeux Olympiques et vraiment voilà moi
c'est ce que je retiens je l'ai dit
plusieurs fois mais
cette présence qu'elle avait dans la pop
culture moi ça me fascine qu'un
personnage qui viennent de se faire
aussi rigide et inspirer des chansons
punk et des séries des films et toucher
autant de gens moi voilà c'est plutôt
cette image qu'elle avait qui dépassait
les les dépassaient les gens qui
dépassaient les registres de culture qui
me qui restera merci beaucoup Pascaline
21h08 nous sommes en direct nous sommes
le 8 septembre 2022 et la reine
d'Angleterre et donc décédé à 96 ans
après 70 ans de règne toute la journée
nous avions senti venir cette nouvelle
avec toute la famille royale qui se
rendait progressivement dans ce château
de Balmoral en Écosse où elle passait
habituellement la fin de son été et où
elle était restée jusqu'au au mois de
septembre un communiqué qui disait que
son état était préoccupant et vers la
nouvelle est tombée tout à l'heure le
prince Charles n’est plus prince il
devient roi il devrait s'exprimer dans
la soirée le roi Charles III je vous
propose qu'on écoute lise trust la
première ministre elle s'est exprimée
tout à l'heure c'était au moment où on
prenait l'antenne on a raté ça c'était
la fin de son intervention on l'écoute
première intervention très importante
les premières ministres que depuis deux
jours
[Musique]
populaire je vous propose que l'on
puisse retracer son destin avec Stéphane
Bern qui mieux que lui pour nous parler
de la reine d'Angleterre on écoute
c'est une reine qui était populaire mais
pas au sens où nous l'entendons
nous on regarde la cote de popularité de
nos dirigeants elle elle est à plus de
80% évidemment de code de popularité
mais c'est une femme qui ne cherchait
pas le être aimé elle cherchait être
respectée elle voulait que l'institution
soit aimée
que la couronne soit soit révérée vénéré
peut-être mais elle ne cherchait pas la
popularité pour elle-même j'étais
toujours été surpris en la en la voyant
[Musique]
c'est la foule la tant partout
alors elle va très gentiment prendre un
bouquet on la photographie elle sourit
peut-être un petit signe discret de la
main mais jamais plus
la plupart des autres quand ils voient
des foules qui les applaudissent mais
mais agite les mains pendant des heures
pour pour répondre non elle cherchait
pas vous voyez les acclamations les
vivav les elle cherchait pas à être
populaire dans ce sens là cette
conscience qu'elle avait d'être quelque
chose de plus grand qu'elle m'aime
quelque chose qu'il a dépassait et puis
c'est une femme qui a qui a fait son
devoir et je crois voyez-vous qu'alors
que toutes les institutions se sont
effondrées
particulièrement avec le brexit tous les
gens ont perdu confiance dans le monde
politique aussi les promesses non tenues
les atermoiements les l'institution est
restée malgré toutes les avanies les
malgré tous les ans toutes les embûches
l'institution est restée
à garder le respect du public et je
crois que ça c'est pour elle c'était le
plus important
c'était une femme qui n'est pas à la
mode
être dans le vent est une ambition de
feuilles mortes disait un poète au 17e
siècle c'est pas faux
elle ne cherchez pas être on dit avec
cette tenue acidulée oui elle était vue
de partout en même temps il a suffi
d'attendre quelques années pour devenir
une icône même aux yeux d'un aventure la
papesse de la mode du Vogue
international c'est vous dire mais elle
cherchait pas à être à la mode elle
cherchait pas à être donc elle était de
cette image rassurante de la granny
préféré des Anglais
[Musique]
yes cet épisode dans dans la vie de la
reine de la mort de Diana elle a pas été
compris sur le moment mais je crois
qu'avec le recul les gens ont vraiment
ressenti ce qu'elle voulait dire c'est
que oui on peut éprouver de la peine
mais en tant que mère et grand-mère de
la nation en tant que incarnation vivant
de la nation on ne peut pas s'abaisser à
à pleurnicher à exprimer sa peine c'est
des moments où tout d'un coup il y a des
il y a des décalages avec l'opinion
publique alors est-ce qu'il faut
toujours suivre l'opinion publique ou
est-ce que on doit pas rester soi-même
dans l'épisode de la mort de Diana elle
est restée elle-même moi je crois
qu'elle a eu raison à la protéger ses
petits fils elle n'a pensé qu'à cela
protéger où il y a Marie de cette
hystérie collective de ce drame qui a
ensuite au lieu d'aller pleurnicher a
fait une déclaration à la télévision
une déclaration qui a changé le cours
des choses mais c'était elle a dit nous
devons tirer les leçons de la mort de
Diana cette simple petite phrase a tout
changé le pignon a retrouvé sa reine ça
y est mais vous avez c'est c'était pas
popularité n'a pas été bréchée c'était
une demande d'amour c'était note on est
dans le chagrin on veut que maman nous
console et donc on attendait que maman
nous console
[Musique]
21h14 nous sommes en direct la reine
d'Angleterre et décédée à laver 96 ans
décédé ce jeudi 8 septembre 2022 après
70 ans de règne soit spéciale évidemment
avec deux nouveaux invités qui m'ont
rejoint Jacques Pessi bonjour bonjour
spécialiste des têtes couronnées aux
figures
vous allez me donner des anecdotes
j'espère et puis florentin Colomb merci
d'être ici vous avez été correspondant
pendant 8 ans entre 2011 et 2019 à
Londres on imagine que la Londe est en
émoi alors on se parle bah complètement
c'est un moment qui était attendu
peut-être que tout le monde savait que
ça arriverait un jour et redouter tout a
été bousculé aujourd'hui c'était une
journée assez curieuse parce que on a eu
ce communiqué de presse
un petit peu mystérieux ce matin
était sous supervision sous surveillance
médicale c'est ça donc tout s'est arrêté
la séance au Parlement a été interrompue
la première ministre du stress a dû
sortir de la séance alors qu'elle
présentait un plan massif pour
l'économie sur l'inflation et les prix
de l'énergie la dû partir on a vu tout
d'un coup une espèce de de défervescence
et les chaînes de télévision sont
passées en spécial toute la journée et
on a vu l'un des présentateurs de BBC
News en noir ce qui était signe que on
était proche du deuil de la nation qui a
été annoncé un petit peu plus tard dans
la soirée Jacques c'est un moment qui
était prévu on a un protocole très
précis pour cet événement qui devait
arriver elle avait 96 ans oui c'est déjà
fabuleux qu'elle est réunie autant mais
ce qui est étonnant c'est qu'on sait pas
toujours qu'elle a compris à l'âge de 10
ans et 8 mois qu'elle allait réunir car
en effet lorsque il y a eu son père à
accéder au trône ce n'était pas prévu
elle a su que c'était son oncle c'était
son nom et ça a été fini donc ce qui
s'est passé c'est que elle a compris ce
jour-là elle a commencé à travailler à
son futur métier de reine elle avait
déjà un admirateur qui était Winston
Churchill et il disait mais elle est
extraordinaire elle a un pouvoir de
travail incroyable et c'est comme ça que
petit à petit elle a appris son métier
avec une éducation très stricte et puis
l'amour de la France et de la rue très
tôt ah alors attendez vous me parlez de
tous les sujets en même temps on a le
temps d'y revenir Jacques pas de souci
on va parler de tout ça florentin est-ce
que vous quand vous étiez correspondant
de 2011 à 2019 vous attendiez à ce
moment j'imagine que à chaque fois qu'il
y a une petite inflexion dans la santé
de la reine de tous les journalistes qui
sont basés à Londres et en particulier
les correspondants étrangers parce qu'on
se dit le moment où on va quitter le
pays pour partir en vacances ou voyager
on prend le risque de ne pas être là
pour ce moment cet événement massif et
c'est vrai que c'est dans la tête depuis
pour moi une décennie mais d'autres
plusieurs décennies de correspondant
étrangers à Londres et de journalistes
britanniques
et comme vous le disiez il y a tout un
protocole tout a été très préparé le
protocole London c'est le nom de code de
parce que l'enterrement de chaque
personne de la famille royale le projet
de funérailles est préparé longtemps à
l'avance et
décrit dans des manuels très très
importants
sous un autre modernisé au fur et à
mesure que les époques
c'est mis à jour régulièrement en
fonction de qui et qui est qui est à
quel poste à quel moment et donc pour la
reine Elizabeth c'était London Bridge is
fall at fallen donc le pont de le pont
de Londres est tombé nous avons les
images en direct devant Buckingham
Palace ou les Anglais ce massent
évidemment pour rendre hommage à la à la
reine d'Angleterre je vous cite ce tweet
d'Emmanuel Macron Sa Majesté la Reine
Elizabeth 2 à incarner la continuité et
l'unité de la nation britannique plus de
70 ans durant je regarde le souvenir
d'une amie de la France une reine de
cœur qui a marqué à jamais son pays et
son vous alliez me parler de son amour
pour la France et on a entendu il y a
quelques instants parler français
parlait bien français
et en plus avant de devenir reine
sachant que la dernière reine elle est
partie en France elle est venue
incognito en France encore avec son
fiancé en 47 allez à 40 ans avec
Philippe dedimbourg ils ont c'était la
Pentecôte ils ont passé 4 jours
idyllique à visiter Paris en un temps où
il y avait pas d'embouteillages et ils
sont repartis totalement incognito et
ensuite elle est venue en cette époque
débarqué dans Paris incognito il ne
resterait pas longtemps je pense qu'il y
aurait pas de souci mais elle était pas
encore reine elle était princesse à
l'époque il faut savoir quand elle est
devenu reine le premier séjour officiel
en France avec René Coty il y a un dîner
à l'Élysée où elle fait un discours dans
un français impeccable elle remonte les
Champs-Élysées jusqu'à l'Arc de Triomphe
c'est en 57 regardez on a des images 11
avril 57 avec René Coty et elle parle
français racontez-moi cette histoire
elle fait son discours elle fait un long
discours en français qu'elle a préparé
car elle ne les à l'époque elle
préparait ses discours parce qu'il y a
une chose qu'il faut savoir et vous ne
savez sans doute c'est que la reine
travaillait énormément ah oui
c'est-à-dire que du matin au soir et du
soir au matin elle était à son poste
c'était pas une reine potiche elle
disait bon elle préparait tous les menus
du jour ça c'était une obligation
d'accord mais à côté elle disait tous
les discours du Parlement et quand même
quelque chose qui lui plaisait pas elle
intervenait auprès du Premier ministre
pour que ce soit rectifié c'est quand
même pas si courant de la part d'une
reine justement Florent par hasard du
calendrier il y a deux jours une
nouvelle Première ministre prénommée
alors il y a un protocole le Premier
ministre est obligé de prêter serment si
j'ose dire devant c'est ça peut-être le
terme mais en fait le précédent le
Premier ministre sortant Boris Johnson
doit présenter sa démission à la reine
puisqu'il était mis en minorité dans son
propre parti et la nouvelle chef du
Parti conservateur qui était désigné
donc lundi les stress doit aller
présenter ses respects si on peut dire à
la souveraine ou souverain bientôt enfin
à partir de
souverain qui lui donne l'ordre la
mission de former un gouvernement donc
c'est comme ça que ça se passe c'est le
monarque constitutionnel qui donne au
Premier ministre qui est la charge de
constituer un gouvernement et quitte si
nécessaire de vérifier que ce
gouvernement a une majorité au Parlement
ce qu'elle a donc là c'était absolument
étonnant dans le déroulement de
l'histoire et l'histoire le retiendra de
voir la nomination de listrose à
Balmoral ce qui était déjà une entorse
au protocole habituelle parce que
normalement ça se déroule à Londres donc
Boris Johnson puis listres sont dû
prendre un avion pour aller à Balmoral
on a vu c'est la dernière photo de la
reine qu'on a vu certains ont dit
qu'elle était mal en point c'est vrai
qu'elle a l'air un petit peu frêle mais
enfin elle souriait devant la nouvelle
Première ministre et on a cette entrée
en fonction absolument incroyable
finalement de listrus dans cette
nouvelle ère sous le règne maintenant du
roi Charles III et ça va remettre
presque tous les compteurs à zéro de
du royaume britannique oui la reine
d'Angleterre alors et je me retourne
vers vous au nouveau Jacques mais vous
étiez entre 2011 et 2009 2019 avec un
épisode important du Royaume-Uni le
brexit elle est restée tout le temps
vous avez raison c'est son rôle et c'est
sa fonction des gens certains se sont
étonnés voire indignés qu'elles ne
prennent pas parti c'était assez amusant
de voir la presse lui imputer de pencher
dans un camp ou dans l'autre on a vu des
une des deux côtés disons que la reine
était pro-européenne avec
le moindre disque alors il y a eu un
jour quand elle a fait un discours de
l'état de le discours de la reine au
Parlement elle avait porté un chapeau
avec bleu avec des fleurs jaunes et on a
dit que c'était un symbole du drapeau
européen et qu'elle affichait son côté
européen mais c'était complètement une
interprétation enfin chacun voit midi à
sa porte oui et à l'inverse on a des
tabloïd qui faisait la une en disant la
reine soutient le brexit ce qui est tout
aussi faux et c'est le rôle du monarque
constitutionnel britannique de ne pas
prendre parti dans ces affaires
politiques alors comment on peut être
influent sans prendre parti parce
qu'elle travaille en colis elle n'a
jamais accordé la moindre interview ça
ça ne s'est jamais fait elle a fait des
coups fumes comme tourner dans un James
Bond parce qu'elle avait beaucoup
d'humour
et surtout elle a eu une influence en
coulisses par la façon dont elle
travaillait par la façon dont elle
intervenait auprès du Premier ministre
elle avait cette influence pour garder
me semble-t-il à son pays la tradition
qu'elle défendait disons que la reine
est en charge responsable des traditions
d'un certain protocole etc l'influence
il faut voir c'est sûr que elle a ses
entretiens hebdomadaires avec le Premier
ministre confidentiel en tête-à-tête
sans conseiller sans aucun témoin donc
on ne sait toutes les semaines avec les
15 premiers ministres qu'elle a eu elle
a eu un entretien très bref avec cette
semaine mais auparavant avec les 14
autres elle les aura plus toutes les
semaines
de leur règne par zoom pendant le covid
mais qu'elle a eu d'ailleurs oui mais
l'influence de la reine théoriquement
elle n'en a pas alors elle peut froncer
les sourcils elle peut demander des
explications ou des questions à son
premier ministre mais elle ne peut pas
peser dans la politique intérieure
j'apprécie et étranger oui évidemment on
remonte un peu le temps et puis on
analysera avec Florentin ces moments que
vous avez passé vous en Angleterre pour
voir l'influence de la de la reine sur
le peuple britannique alors au début
elle doit pas être reine et comment elle
se prépare parce que on arrive à un
couronnement qui va devenir un moment de
télévision assez hallucinant peut-être
le plus grand de l'histoire mais avant
ça doit pas être reine non elle sait
qu'elle sera reine elle travaille elle
se prépare pendant des années et en
février 52 elle est en safari au Kenya
avec son mari Philippe de Namour et elle
apprend la mort du roi elle prend un
avion elle arrive à Londres elle se tait
et elle va immédiatement préparer la il
va y avoir un an avant le couronnement
et ce couronnement il y a des images qui
existent c'est en France un événement
incroyable la télévision on vend on
passe de 20000 à 60000 postes en France
parce que les gens n'ont pas la
télévision on vend des milliers de poste
les gens
pour voir le couronnement ou alors dans
les vitrines des magasins il y a des
télévisions et les gens se masse devant
les vitrines pour voir ce couronnement
commenté à Londres non pas parler aux
hitron parce qu'il est pas encore le
spécialiste mais par Jacques Salbert qui
est alors le correspondant à Londres de
la RTF alors à ce moment-là elle prend
tout de suite le rôle ou c'est difficile
peut-être pour une femme de prendre le
rôle comme ça ou non pas de souci homme
femme il y a pas de question elle avait
une autorité extraordinaire il faut
quand on se souvient de son mariage
extraordinaire elle rencontre Philippe
mandaten elle a 13 ans elle tombe
amoureuse c'est un peu tôt donc six ans
plus tard juste un coureur de jupons 6
ans plus tard il se retrouve et il se
fiance et il se quitte plus c'est un
coup de foudre immédiat et normalement
la tradition veut qu'elle devienne une
c'est le mari et bien la résister elle
est restée une Windsor à tel point que
Philippe a dit un jour finalement dans
cette dans cette monarchie je ne suis
qu'une amie c'était extraordinaire et
c'est vrai qu'elle a elle a vu une
poigne qu'on ne peut pas imaginer pas
mal de choses dans la vie privée avec
tout ce que sa famille lui a fait est
vraiment elle a toujours résisté avec un
flemme britannique
quel est l'image bon alors on imagine
beaucoup d'amour des Anglais pour elle
mais on a du mal à se le représenter en
France qu'est-ce que c'est au quotidien
au jour le jour est-ce que les Anglais
se lèvent en pensant à la reine
peut-être pas mais tous les jours avant
d'aller travailler non je pense pas en
fait la reine fait partie du paysage et
la monarchie fait partie de on respire
sous une monarchie en Grande-Bretagne
comme comme on pense autant mais
la Reine est très populaire adorée par
les Britanniques ou était
et la monarchie également grâce à elle
c'est à dire que il y a environ moins de
15% des Britanniques qui se ressenti
monarchiste et pour le passage à une
république on verra si ça ne change pas
vous pensez que ça peut évoluer d'autres
émissions pour en parler mais c'est un
des grands grands défis du ah
c'est-à-dire que de la transition
bien entendu et j'ai vu justement je
disais il y a moins de 15 % de
britannique j'ai déjà en compte d'anti
monarchistes pardon j'ai déjà rencontré
des gens qui me disaient moi je suis
République hein et c'était des gens qui
lors du jubilé de diamant de la reine
qui était allé se poster sur un pont
pour l'avoir passé alors qu'ils étaient
antimoriste c'était il y avait un
sentiment d'adhésion et ça c'est pas par
hasard elle la cultivé elle a passé sa
vie à l'entretenir elle disait je dois
être vu pour être cru et en fait elle
s'est rendu compte à partir d'un moment
dans son règne qu'il fallait qu'elle
soit présente dans la vie des gens et en
réalité il y a une statistique qui dit
que un tiers des Britanniques ont déjà
vu un membre de la famille royale en
personne dont la reine pour certains et
c'est la façon de façon de voir si les
Français ont vu leur président de la
République
ni à aucun membre du gouvernement pas un
tiers des Français et là c'est pour ça
tous ces déplacements ces sorties ces
réceptions par milliers un Buckingham
Palace par milliers de personnes c'est
fait pour diffuser cette espèce d'aura
du monarque pour pas que ce soit
quelqu'un sur son avantage dans son dans
son château isolé comme avait pu l'être
par exemple la reine Victoria et qu'au
contraire le monarque soit accepté par
la population donc c'est comme ça le
lien le lien existe et après il y a eu
des hauts et des bas on a vu les on va
en parler évidemment nous venons de voir
des images en direct devant Buckingham
Palace il pleut sur Londres peut-être
pas étonnant peut-être que le ciel de
Londres pleure c'est la reine
d'Angleterre je salue tous ceux qui nous
rejoignent tous ceux qui mettent des
petits RIP RIP sur Youtube en hommage à
la reine à la reine d'Angleterre alors
beaucoup d'humour la reine d'Angleterre
toujours au-delà de son travail par les
mois de ça on voit ce petit sourire
sarcastique
ces collaborateurs vous avez toujours un
mot pour rire et c'était vraiment
c'était même des moments qui lui faisait
oublier m'a-t-on dit les moments
difficiles de traversés en particulier
avec sa sœur avec la mort avec les
problèmes qu'elle allait avec le prince
Charles et ses autres enfants et
l'humour était important pour elle et
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'elle a
accepté de se donner dans James Bond
c'était le genre d'humour qui qui l'a
fasciné
alors elle a pas vraiment tourné dans un
James Bond elle a tourné un clip avec
Daniel Craig qui incarnait James Bond
pour la cérémonie d'ouverture des Jeux
Olympiques de Londres en 2012 mais pour
la légende
c'est pas vraiment un James Bond mais
c'est qu'elle est avec James Bond et
elle a sauté en parachute enfin
une doublure pour arriver dans le stade
olympique GTA c'était absolument
extraordinaire à bord parce que 2
minutes plus tard elle était là en chair
et en os la vraie reine dans le même
costume un peu rose comme ça d'ailleurs
un peu rose dans lequel dans lequel on
l'avait vu sauter en parachute quelques
minutes auparavant allez on va continuer
à parler de la reine d'Angleterre
évidemment il est 21h30 presque 21h30
sur le Figaro live nous passons une
soirée spéciale pour rendre hommage à la
reine d'Angleterre et je veux qu'on se
projette un petit peu on va parler du
prince non non du roi du roi Charles il
faut s'habituer ce soir je vous le dis
depuis le début de cette émission on a
commencé à 20h le fait la faute à chaque
fois quand Charles ça sort tout seul ça
va être à ce nouveau roi mais ça va être
très difficile parce que après 70 ans de
règne de la même du même monarque
d'Elizabeth II il faut s'habituer à
celui qu'on connaît depuis puisqu'il a
73 ans depuis 73 ans comme le prince de
Galles ou le prince Charles et déjà et
désormais ce soir devenu Charles III
c'était pas automatique parce que le
nouveau souverain peut choisir son nom
le son nom de règne il aurait pu choisir
autre chose même s'il s'appelle Charles
il aurait pu choisir de s'appeler
Frédéric ouédouard ou autre chose en
tant que roi d'accord
donc Charles III donc c'est le nouveau
roi son épouse Camilla est la reine
consort ça c'est assez nouveau aussi et
ça a été contesté ça n'allait pas de soi
et le prince William et devient le
prince de Galles et la princesse Kate la
duchesse celle qui était duchesse de
Cambridge devient la nouvelle princesse
de Galles donc il faut s'habituer en
effet à ces changements de titre le
prince Charles quelle éducation vous
voyez le roi Charles quelle éducation
a-t-il ben là aussi il y a eu quelque
chose qui est que la reine a fait que
Personne n'avait fait avant elle car
d'habitude un souverain est élevé avec
des précepteurs au palais et là elle a
décidé qu'il irait à l'école pour
connaître le peuple et il a fait l'école
primaire le prince Charles avec son père
et sa mère qui venait le chercher à la
sortie et je crois que ça a été très
important de son éducation parce qu'il a
été confronté à d'autres enfants et
encore une fois elle y tenait parce que
ça faisait partie des choses elle
préparait son fils sans savoir
elle préparait son fils au couronnement
donc à connaître vraiment le peuple il a
aussi été envoyé dans un pensionnat
après pendant ces années collège et
lycée en Écosse Gordon Storm qui était
très dur pour lui où il a été harcelé
par ses camarades pas très bien traité
et c'est le prince Philippe qui lui son
père qui a décidé de l'envoyer là parce
qu'il était allé à lui-même et à trouver
que c'était formateur que le prince
Charles aille là-bas faire ses études et
ça a été traumatique pour lui il a
détesté cette période mais
en effet ça l'a ouvert vers d'autres
horizons et ça a amené à
fréquenter ses congénères
donc effectivement il y en a beaucoup
souffert pendant qu'on parlait on
parlait de l'humour de la on est passé à
autre chose mais en région on travaille
et on m'a retrouvé on nous a retrouvé on
va pouvoir en profiter de la reine
d'Angleterre il y a peu qui s'est amusés
avec l'ours Paddington vous savez et
bien regardez
avec lui
[Musique]
l'ours Paddington qui fait n'importe
quoi avec une gamme Palace alors c'était
très codifié quand on rencontre la reine
j'ai vu quand il y a un sourire il faut
faire très attention à tout tout et il y
a une tradition qu'elle respectait
absolument je vois la tasse de thé à 16h
c'était le thé avec un petit morceau de
chocolat elle n'a jamais dérogé à cette
règle ou elle se trouvait un jour on va
raconter elle était arrivée à vos
manières en Provence est arrivé avec son
pour dormir et bien il y avait l'eau et
l'eau pour le thé et le thé dans les
valises pour qu'elles prennent le thé
habituel de l'Angleterre ce qu'il y a eu
des moments dans le règne de de cette
reine où son image a pu être écornée à
flancher un peu et je pense à la période
Lady Di
Charles et je me suis dit il y a quelque
chose qui va pas la famille royale qui a
peut-être été l'un des soucis de la
reine d'Angleterre tout au long de son
règne vous avez vécu le brexit
évidemment lorsque vous étiez
correspondant au Royaume-Uni et à
Londres vous avez vécu aussi la tragédie
s'ils veulent se dire du prince Harry ça
a pris beaucoup de place à au
Royaume-Uni et en fait il y a eu il y a
eu beaucoup quand même de soubresauts
dans la vie de cette famille royale sous
le règne d'Elizabeth 2 et elle a dû
gérer ça contre le ventes et marées on
va dire et faire contre mauvaise fortune
bon coin il y a eu avant Harry et Meghan
il y a eu l'anus horribilis en 1992 ou
trois de ses enfants ou divorcé en plus
le château de Windsor a pris feu cette
année-là donc elle a pas eu que des
moments en glorieux ensuite il y a eu en
effet le mariage du prince Harry avec
Megan qui sait très bien passé dans un
premier temps et puis peu à peu il y a
créer une nouvelle crise monarchique et
puis il y a eu les déboires beaucoup
plus graves de son fils Andrew était
mêlé rappelez-nous ce que c'est pour
ceux qui nous rejoignent et qui ne
savent pas forcément de quoi on parle le
fiston andrew est le prince Andrew et le
fils préféré de la reine en fait tout le
monde pense ou donc c'est le savoir de
Charles et le petit frère de Charles et
c'est un bon vivant quelqu'un qui a
beaucoup vécu sur le sur le système de
la couronne de la monarchie
de stars etc et il a beaucoup fréquenté
Jeff line aux États-Unis qui est mort en
prison mais était poursuivi pour des
histoires de pédophilie et
il a fallu que la reine
[Musique]
écarte le prince Andrew de toute
responsabilité officielle et c'était pas
plus tard que l'année dernière donc une
fin de règne difficile à gérer pour elle
aussi sur ce plan les médias pour parler
parce qu'ils ont été très présents dans
toutes ces périodes évidemment c'était
une femme de on a parlé tout à l'heure
de de son couronnement parliez de
l'Eurovision juste avant qu'on prenne
l'antenne c'était c'était la première
retransmission en Eurovision ce
couronnement et ça a été un événement
mondial il n'y a jamais eu de avant elle
de couronnement de ce genre après ça a
suivi avec toutes les princes tous les
rois mais sérieusement elle était très
présente dans les médias sans jamais y
être un paradoxe en tout cas je crois
c'est un cas
uniquement
on n'a jamais répondu mais en revanche
le palais ça fait très bien utiliser les
médias et à un moment où la famille
royale était pas très populaire à la fin
des années 60 on les trouvait trop
distant que il vivait sur le dos etc le
Buckingham Palace a accepté ou même
commandé un documentaire sur la BBC sur
la vie de la famille royale et on voyait
c'est absolument extraordinaire la reine
Elizabeth son mari ses enfants à
Balmoral en Écosse faire des
pique-niques la reine faire la vaisselle
le prince Philippe vers le barbecue
les enfants jouer avec leurs parents
comme une famille normale et ça a été
donc on contrôle quand même c'est
absolument contrôlé tellement contrôlé
que le documentaire a disparu de tout de
YouTube etc il est absolument invisible
maintenant on verra s'il fait surface un
peu plus tard mais ce documentaire avec
fait énormément pour
pour accroître améliorer la popularité
de la reine et de sa famille Jacques
Plessis tiens j'ai une question pour
vous est-ce que vous savez ce qui va
changer là dans les dans les jours à
venir avec l'arrivée du nouveau roi
Charles III il y a une période de deuil
il ne va pas être il ne va pas être tout
de suite roi
Isabelle n'avait pas été tout de suite
reine donc ce qui va changer qu'est-ce
qui peut changer moi je ne sais pas
depuis longtemps vont commencer à
apparaître sur les pièces de monnaie et
les billets de banque au Royaume-Uni et
dans d'autres pays du monde le visage le
prof du roi Charles et c'est absolument
extraordinaire parce que sur toutes les
boîtes aux lettres rouges les fameuses
boîtes aux lettres rouges il y a les
initiales I a Elisabeth Regina ça veut
dire Elizabeth la reine Elizabeth va
falloir les changer progressivement
peut-être pas dans la nuit pour que il y
ait les initiales de charge et moi on me
baladant dans la campagne anglaise j'ai
vu une fois une boîte aux lettres avec
écrit gr donc George Rex c'est-à-dire le
père de cette boîte aux lettres là
n'avait pas été changée depuis que la
reine Elizabeth était montée
pièce sont prêts depuis longtemps
ils ont prévu du coup dire que les
timbres ils vont sortir très très vite
on imagine qu'ils ont pas fait en
quelques jours alors j'ai une autre
question pour vous j'ai posé la question
tout à l'heure avec successeur à Londres
Arnaud Delagrange très complet qui m'a
tout raconté mais il a collé je l'ai
collé sur une une question est-ce que
l'hymne va changer est-ce qu'il va
devenir bien sûr c'est fascinant mais
j'ai des amis qui sont nés il y a pas si
longtemps que ça enfin mettons à 30 ans
qui ont toujours vécu anglais donc
toujours vécu en chantant à l'école god
save the queen et qui vont devoir passer
à God Save The King et c'est vraiment
c'est pareil comme c'était jadis mais il
y a plus de 70 ans bon je vous propose
qu'on fasse un petit tour on rappelle en
images sa vie sa vie la vie d'Elizabeth
II au service du royaume regardez
écoutez
la reine Elizabeth II
en prenant ses fonctions à l'âge de 27
ans elle est devenue la reine du
Royaume-Uni de Grande-Bretagne et
d'Irlande du Nord et de ses autres
royaumes 16 au total
elle a régné sur le Royaume-Uni depuis
succédant à son père le roi George VI
qui lui-même avait succédé à son frère
Edouard VIII ce dernier ayant abdiqué
pour pouvoir épouser une femme divorcée
[Musique]
l'évolution de la société et des mœurs
ont obligé Elisabeth II à consentir au
divorce de Troyes de ses quatre enfants
en 1992 à se rapprocher de son peuple au
moment de la mort de Lady Di en 1997 et
a accepté le mariage de son petit-fils
Harry avec une Américaine divorcée et
métisse en 2018
[Musique]
son pouvoir s'est traduit par une
influence politique ayant un accès
privilégié au Premier ministre
britannique avec qui elle avait un
entretien hebdomadaire
[Musique]
c'est comme ça qu'en 1991 elle a imposé
la présence de Nelson Mandela au sommet
du Commonwealth bien qu'il ne soit pas
encore président de l'Afrique du Sud
rompant ainsi avec le protocole
tout au long de son règne qui fut le
plus long de l'histoire du Royaume-Uni
dépassant en 2015 celui de son aïeul la
reine Victoria
le monarque a le devoir d'offrir une
continuité et une unité à la nation
la longévité du règne d'Elizabeth II a
permis de maintenir la symbolique et
l'attachement des Anglais à la monarchie
[Musique]
21h42 nous sommes en direct ce jeudi 8
septembre 2022 qui restera un jour gravé
dans l'histoire avec le décès de la
reine Elizabeth II elle avait 96 ans
elle avait régné pendant 70 ans Jacques
Pessi est toujours avec nous une
question pour vous allez me
connaissez-vous
en fait je crois qu'elle ne savait pas
où mettre ses mains donc c'est pour ça
que le 5ème
ministre dans dans son palais à
Buckingham Palace ou n'importe qui elle
avait toujours son petit sac alors
qu'elle était chez elle quand même
je crois que c'est vraiment elle savait
pas quoi faire de ses mains que c'était
un accessoire indispensable je suis pas
sûr qu'il y a grand chose dans le sac
d'ailleurs
j'ai entendu que c'est elle qui avait
envoyé le premier email parce que c'est
elle qui avait fait les qui avait
utilisé le prototype finalement des
internet c'est elle qui avait envoyé
les hommages qui se succèdent du pape
profondément attristé François qui dit
prier pour Elisabeth II et pour Charles
III évidemment alors c'était la reine
pas uniquement du Royaume-Uni le
Commonwealth elle représentait
le royaume partout dans le monde ce
qu'il faut ce dont ce qu'il faut
rappeler c'est que quand elle est
arrivée sur le trône en 1952 elle était
la reine d'un empire oui d'un très grand
empire du plus grand qu'il s'est
désagrégé avec son passage il s'est
désagrégé on va pas lui imputer la
responsabilité parce que ça ça a eu lieu
pour quasiment tous les empires en même
temps c'est le sens de l'histoire mais
c'est en tout cas ça s'est passé sous
son règne et c'est là que son règne
absolument incroyable parce qu'on est
passé d'une époque aujourd'hui qui n'ont
rien à voir et du coup cet empire c'est
complètement désagrégé avec la dé- la
décolonisation et l'indépendance de ses
anciens de ses anciennes colonies mais
la Reine a souhaité conserver ses liens
qui attachait
pays à la Royaume-Uni et du coup est né
le Commonwealth qui est devenu une sorte
d'ersatz d'Empire qui est devenu une
libre association de pays qui représente
56 pays dans le monde ancienne colonie
presque toutes ancienne colonie
britannique parce que d'autres l'ont
rejoint depuis et puis la reine était
aussi souveraine de 15 États dont le
Canada l'Australie oui je vous le relie
le match de Trudeau tout à l'heure le
Premier ministre canadien qui dit
qu'elle a représenté une partie
importante de l'histoire du Canada c'est
le moins qu'on puisse dire puisque c'est
le chef de l'État du Canada c'est la
souveraine du Canada il faut savoir que
quand elle est devenue reine et avant
d'être couronné pendant les six mois
elle avait hésité tous les pays à un
pour connaître ces sujets c'était
vraiment obligatoire avant ce
couronnement déjà que le peuple la
connaisse
nous avons des images devant Buckingham
Palace ou les Anglais se massent
progressivement avec leur parapluie on
imagine que là alors je sais pas c'est
très grand devant
de personnes mais c'est un peu
surréaliste enfin on voit ces gens se
masser devant Palace alors que la reine
Elizabeth est décédé à Balmoral donc à
l'autre bout du pays franchement au nord
de l'Écosse et que elle ne vivait plus à
Buckingham Palace en réalité elle est
passée c'était comme un bureau mais
quand elle était à Londres elle
préférait résider à Windsor donc bon
évidemment c'est le symbole c'est un
lieu le lieu le cœur de la monarchie
britannique d'ailleurs on peut se
demander si le prince le prince Charles
ou le nouveau roi Charles III voudra
toujours régner à Buckingham Palace
parce qu'il y a une époque où c'était en
question il voulait une monarchie plus
simple plus réduite et peut-être garder
Buckingham Palace comme comme quartier
général de la monarchie comme comme
siège mais pas forcément irrésistait
mauvaise idée donc bon évidemment pour
toute personne qui passe par Londres
backing Impala c'est le symbole de la
monarchie mais aller devant Buckingham
Palace ce soir sous la pluie franchement
on comprend que les gens aient envie de
faire hommage mais de de donner leurs
hommages mais franchement de
rassemblement
spontané non mais c'est quand même le
meilleur hommage qu'il puisse faire à la
reine c'est vrai ils aimaient leur reine
et ils lui rendent mal je sais pas mais
en revanche on verra des centaines de
milliers de personnes si ce n'est des
millions venir lui rendre hommage quand
son corps sera ramené à Londres et ça va
être le cas dans quelques jours parce
que il devrait être exposé selon le
protocole en Écosse le protocole le
protocole est établi c'est ce dont on
parlait tout à l'heure pour ceux qui
n'ont rien forcément
jusqu'au funérailles de la Reine
Elizabeth chaque jour est codifiée avec
un certain nombre d'événements donc
comme morte en Écosse son corps devrait
être exposé devant le peuple écossais à
Édimbourg on a une certaine durée un
jour ou deux ou plusieurs jours ensuite
son corps devrait être ramené à Londres
en train et exposer à Buckingham Palace
dans la salle du trône de Buckingham
Palace pendant quelques jours ensuite
son corps devrait être exposé à la
Westminster à l'abbaye de Westminster
probablement plusieurs jours pendant
tous ces jours de deuil national les
Britanniques et les étrangers qui sont
pas sages pourront aller rendre hommage
à la reine et on va voir des centaines
de milliers ou des millions de personnes
faire la queue nuit et jour pour rendre
cette hommage à la reine avant les
funérailles qui seront un événement
absolument planétaire c'est dans 10
jours les funérailles alors après le
protocole pas avant un an et le prince
Charles n'est pas roi officiellement le
prince le lendemain de la mort
d'Elizabeth d'ailleurs il a été dit dès
ce soir le Premier ministre a dommage au
roi Charles III donc il est roi il
continue il va être proclamé roi demain
et il sera couronné plus tard mais ça ça
reste à déterminer la date de son
couronnement avec la cérémonie un an
elle avait choisi la reine pour avoir le
temps mais ça peut être beaucoup plus
tôt dans un mois nous suivrons est-ce
qu'il est possible tiens qu'il renonce
là dans les jours à venir parce que
j'entends beaucoup ah il est déjà vieux
le roi Charles mais on ne choisit pas
dans la monarchie le l'héritier du trône
ne choisit pas à quel âge il va hériter
du trône donc c'est pas comme se
présenter aux élections présidentielles
et à l'inverse le peuple ou l'opinion ne
choisit pas qui va succéder à la reine
Elizabeth donc depuis le début c'est le
fils aîné
et si elle avait eu une fille la loi a
changé une fille aînée elle a une fille
cadette si elle avait une fille est née
la loi a changé sa fille aurait été
épreuve elle était reine oui mais elle
n'avait pas de frère à l'époque elle
n'aurait pas été reine si elle avait eu
un frère
donc tout ça pour dire que le prince
Charles fils aîné de la reine depuis le
jour de sa naissance il est à 73 ans
allait succéder à la reine Elizabeth il
ne risque pas de renoncer parce qu'il a
tant ce jour depuis 73 ans sans
souhaiter la mort de sa mère évidemment
ce qui était très ambiguë très très
compliqué à gérer de sa part mais il
aspire complètement à être roi il sera
roi c'est pas parce que les gens
préfèrent William ou préféreraient
William que c'est pas un concours de
beauté c'est pas une élection donc c'est
ça la différence oui mais vous me disiez
tout à l'heure et je me tourne vers vous
Jacques
il sera moins populaire que la reine
d'Angleterre et il est moins populaire
que son fils est-ce que il peut pardon
s'aborder la royauté et d'abord d'abord
il faut attendre pour voir parce que
c'est dans sa tête et dans je vous ai
parlé et je pense beaucoup plus
intelligent qu'on le dit beaucoup plus
discret effectivement il a attendu ce
jour c'est un seigneur mais il a eu le
temps d'avoir l'expérience il a quand
même fait beaucoup de choses il a été
éduqué ces derniers mois et ces
dernières années il commençait déjà à
prendre progressivement la place de sa
mère au discours du Trône par exemple au
mois de au mois d'avril bien sûr et puis
même avant pendant des années il a fait
des voyages des réceptions officiels
Camilla est entré dans la vie de Charles
et finalement la reine a accepté parce
qu'elle savait que Charles prendrait sa
succession et que Kamila était avait un
avantage aussi c'est qu'elle était une
femme discrète comme elle et une femme
discrète ça ça plaisait à la reine
Elizabeth c'est un une journée assez
exceptionnelle 8 septembre 2022 la reine
d'Angleterre est décédée regardez la Une
du Figaro de demain l'adieu à la reine
avec cette édito en dessous que vous
pourrez lire des tiennes de montêtier
alors pourquoi cette fascination on
parlait de l'importance de à travers le
monde dans les différents pays qui sont
des anciennes colonies anglaises en
France il y a une fascination pour la
reine d'Angleterre mais comme il y a eu
une fascination pour Grâce de Monaco à
une époque qui est morte voici 40 ans
alors les Français veulent couper la
tête des rois mais il les aime quand
même et c'est les rois et les reines
font partie de notre patrimoine dans le
monde entier et la reine en est un
exemple qui en a eu d'autres et ça fait
partie de l'adrénaline des Français
c'est une femme qui a fait rêver bien
des Français c'est une femme qui est un
symbole aussi de
d'un pays 70 ans de règne un qui a fait
ça Louis XIV 72 exactement d'ailleurs le
lien n'est pas complètement artificielle
et parce que cette fascination de la
France pour cette monarchie de nos
voisins britanniques elle est liée à
notre passé de monarchie cette histoire
que l'on a et en France on a eu pendant
des siècles une monarchie absolue qu'on
a décidé d'arrêter
progressivement enfin 1789
et il y a toujours eu un rapport un
petit peu ambigu de la société française
on va dire ou de des citoyens français
avec avec ce passé qui a été tranchée
sans jeu de mots mais mais qui reste
quand même il reste une ambiguïté dans
l'esprit des gens
vous restez encore quelques minutes avec
nous et on continue cette soirée
spéciale pour le décès de la reine
d'Angleterre
les derniers jours est-ce que on l'avait
senti venir est-ce que il y avait une
tension à part avant même se communiquer
tout à l'heure ça fait quelques jours ça
fait plusieurs mois que la reine a des
problèmes de mobilité ça ça a été
d'accepter le palais elle se déplace
avec une canne elle a annulé beaucoup
d'engagement par son jubilé à son jubilé
à la participé mais chaque jour on
n'était pas sûr laquelle événement elle
allait pouvoir participer donc elle a
fait une sorte de service minimum elle
est apparue tout à fait mais pas à tous
les événements du jubilé et puis depuis
quelques jours il y avait encore plus
d'inquiétude puisque quand l'istre a
succédé à Boris Johnson on a dit que la
passation de pouvoir enfin le changement
de Premier ministre devant la reine
allait se faire à Balmoral et non pas à
Londres comme c'est l'habitude et puis
ce weekend la reine devait participer à
une cérémonie à des jeux les Highland
Games qui en Écosse il y a dû annuler
aussi donc on savait déjà que elle elle
se portait pas très bien mais c'est vrai
que depuis plusieurs années il y a eu
des moments où elle a eu des passages
habillés des petits moments de faiblesse
elle a dû annuler des choses et puis
après elle s'est reprises très bien mais
là on était vraiment oui
ça a été la mort de son mari
c'est-à-dire que Stella
un an et demi Philippe à 99 ans je pense
que même si elle en parlait jamais ce
qu'elle ne parlait jamais je suis
convaincu qu'elle ne s'en est jamais
remise de l'histoire avec son mari c'est
pas anodin ah bah c'est pas anodin
puisqu'elle tombe amoureuse de lui à 13
ans et dans un dîner officiel bien sûr
il se passe rien et six ans plus tard il
se retrouve un peu par hasard il a
beaucoup navigué il est beaucoup voyagé
et c'est le coup de foudre et ne se
quitteront plus jamais elle a dit il
elle a 19 ans
ça fait longtemps et ça a été un couple
avec des hauts et des bas parce que
Philippe était aussi quelqu'un de joyeux
mais il a résisté et c'était c'était sa
canne si j'ose dire la canne permanente
assez bonne heure de vivre je pense que
ça disparition est beaucoup dans cette
c'est certain oui elle a dû être très
très
diminué par la mort psychologiquement
par la mort de son mari mais même
physiquement mais moi j'étais très
frappé de voir à quel point elle
maintenait une sorte de grâce
on la voyait souriante depuis la mort de
Philippe
elle n'a pas montré le moindre visage
d'abattement sauf évidemment au moment
de funérailles de Philippe mais
peut-être que c'est funérailles ont été
une sorte d'échauffement est-ce que on
va reproduire le même système
mais justement il y avait beaucoup de
monde on a vu à la télévision à la BBC
etc une espèce de tonalité de deuil
pendant des jours et des jours tout
était en noir il y avait que de la
musique funèbre etc et on se disait mais
qu'est-ce que ça va être pour la reine
et là on ne fait que de commencer à le
voir et on va le voir pendant des jours
et des jours mais je crois que c'est
sans comparaison ce qu'on va voir là et
franchement je pense que c'est sans
comparaison l'événement là sa mort
aujourd'hui mais c'est funérailles et le
l'accession au trône de Charles pour
être un événement comme on en a jamais
vu franchement parce que tous les chefs
d'État du monde vont venir là toutes les
familles royales seront là il y aura des
foules absolument incomparable et puis
on va voir c'est le moment si des
entreprises ou des partis politiques ou
des mauvaises nouvelles à annoncer c'est
le moment de le faire parce que ça
risque de passer un personnage
tout à l'heure vous me posez la question
du sac bien on a un internaute qui vous
donne une réponse Christian Lauwers sur
Youtube qui nous dit le sac de la reine
était un moyen de communiquer avec son
entourage pour dire qu'elle voulait
partir etc donner des indications à la
fin de ses rendez-vous voilà ce que nous
dit Christian et oui évidemment dont
vous évidemment pour cette soirée
spéciale listrus première ministre
depuis deux jours
il a pris la parole tout à l'heure alors
ce discours j'imagine que tous les
premiers ministres depuis des années
devaient l'avoir préparé et devaient le
redouter mistress est là depuis deux
jours elle a pris la parole elle a parlé
de la reine d'Angleterre elle a parlé du
roi d'Angleterre écoute
exactement
oui alors c'est vraiment la fin du nerf
et le début d'une nouvelle ère et on
voit les stress qui est le même est
arrivé à darning Street il y a deux
jours et on sait bien que la longévité
d'un instruite est bien moindre
Buckingham Palace 15 premiers ministres
15 premiers ministres sous le règne
d'Élisabeth II mais quatre premiers
ministres dans les six dernières années
une époque d'instabilité et pour les
stress on va dire que c'est une chance
ce serait cynique mais il y a une
opportunité de remettre à zéro les
choses et de montrer que quel est la
première ministre d'une nouvelle ère
parce que
elle arrive au pouvoir d'une façon pas
forcément très glorieuse parce que elle
a été désignée par son parti après que
son prédécesseur a dû démissionner en
raison de ses phrases etc donc et des
scandales qui ont émaillé
son mandat sont les trois ans qu'il aura
passé à dingue Street donc pour liste il
arrive sans aucune popularité
comme étant présentée comme la
continuité de Boris Johnson et bien là
il y a une occasion en or si je puis
dire de repartir sur de nouvelles bases
c'est ce qu'elle a d'ailleurs fait dans
ce discours je ne lui prête aucune
intention au cynique dans ce discours
mais tout est politique elle a parlé de
la nouvelle ère qui commence sous le
règne de du nouveau roi Charles III on
sait quel était son premier ministre
favori elle l'a jamais dit et je elle
l'a jamais dit elle n'a jamais rien dit
sur ce sujet moi je pense toute façon
qu'elle avait une grande grande
tendresse dans son enfance pour Winston
Churchill il admirait par dessus tout je
crois qu'il y a eu aussi beaucoup de
complicité entre eux parce que c'était
le premier c'était son premier ministre
et c'était un homme politique chevronné
le quand même le le vainqueur de la
guerre bien sûr et il a accepté au début
il s'est dit mais qu'est-ce que c'est
que cette petite princesse là qui
devient reine elle n'y connaît rien et
il a accepté de façon de la prendre sous
son aile de la former de l'épauler ils
se sont mutuellement
aider pendant pendant toute cette
période et je pense que c'est lui qui a
dû rester dans son souvenir comme son
meilleur premier ministre
le premier formateur de la future reine
c'est Winston Churchill qui s'enfermait
qu'il a recevait chez elle il mangeait
bien lui elle lui elle a le droit à une
tasse de thé lui mangez un oiseau et un
homme et il se retirait de temps en
temps dans une pièce où il faisait ses
peintures il passait son temps à part
c'est son grand bonheur et et je crois
qu'un jour même enfant
enfant bien plutôt il a pris Elisabeth
sur ses genoux comme avec un côté
paternel quand elle était enfant oui il
est 22h merci de nous avoir suivi
d'avoir suivi cette soirée spéciale
allez vous partez pas avant de m'avoir
donné une petite anecdote dont vous vous
souviendrez toujours des d'Elisabeth une
image dites moi Jacques Pessi vous qui
avez bien connu toute cette histoire
autour de la Reine Elizabeth
le souvenir d'Elizabeth que je continue
à garder c'est c'est ce qu'on a dit tout
à l'heure c'est c'est humour qu'elle
avait avec ces Jeux Olympiques et tout
ce qu'elle a pu accepter avec l'autre
parkington je trouve qu'il n'y a aucune
trouvez-moi un chef d'État et autant
d'humour qu'elle à Rouen une reine
autant d'humour qu'elle dans l'histoire
de avec du sérieux avec du avec une
rigueur totalement parce que c'est elle
était rigoureuse sérieuse et en même
temps elle avait de l'humour sauf que
quelqu'un qui a de l'humour et qui est
sérieux c'est une femme idéale oui c'est
tout à fait vrai et dans la même veine
je dirais que c'était quand même la plus
grande reine qu'on est connue la plus
grande monarque qu'on est connue et bien
elle est venue en visite sa dernière
visite à Paris en 2014 avait été reçue
pour un banquet pour un dîner d'État à
l'Elysée par François Hollande à
l'époque et puis elle a inauguré le
marché aux fleurs enfin elle était au
marché aux fleurs sur l'île de la cité
était
et puis il s'est mis il va pleuvoir et
vous connaissez
son parapluie et année d'algo avait un
porteur de parapluie derrière elle on
voit qu'il a la reine je vous remontre
cette Une du Figaro vous allez
évidemment vous ruer dans les kiosques
pour l'acheter parce que c'est une une
qui restera mythique évidemment l'adieu
à la reine à rock pour son royaume c'est
l'éditorial des tiennes de monter ici
merci beaucoup messieurs merci à vous de
nous avoir suivis on reste ensemble le
flux comme on dit ne se coupe pas on va
aller à Buckingham Palace prendre un peu
l'ambiance et puis tout au long de la
soirée on continuera à voir ces
documents exceptionnels avec notamment
les commentaires de Stéphane Bern voilà
pour les images à Buckingham ou les
Anglais se réunissent ce soir sous la
pluie c'est très anglais avec leur
parapluie
merci beaucoup bonne soirée
Elisabeth et est devenue reine par
accident en 1952 sans y avoir été
préparé mais auparavant elle était
princesse
héritière sans l'avoir vraiment désirée
en 1952 à la mort de son père contre
prématuré donc elle devient reine elle
apprend cela quand elle est perchée en
haut d'un figuier au Kenya enfin en tout
cas elle est là quand ce produit la mort
prématurée du roi Jean justice et c'est
un choc pour elle même si elle s'y était
préparée parce que elle a 25 ans elle
devient reine le prince Philippe devient
prince qu'on sort et ils ont déjà deux
enfants Charles Nay en 48 et Anne en
1950 et elle est projetée elle devient
une toute jeune reine
[Musique]
trois personnes vont la guider la reine
Victoria d'abord quel est le pense son
père le roi George VI elle se demande
toujours qu'aurait fait mon père en de
telle circonstance et puis enfin son
premier ministre le premier de ces 14
premiers ministres et c'est Winston
Churchill qui est un peu son mentor et
son guide il lui tient la main en
quelque sorte de toute jeune reine
elle apprend sur le tas évidemment parce
que elle a pas eu le temps de se
préparer aux affaires de l'État donc oui
elle est devenue reine par accident
elle est devenue très vite la femme la
mieux renseignée du pays on raconte que
dans ces jeunes années très vite elle
prend à revers son premier ministre
Winston Churchill en interrogeant sur
des dépêches diplomatiques qui viennent
d'arriver et que lui Apple lui en disant
j'ai rendez-vous avec la reine elle va
passer là-dessus mais non elle passe pas
là dessus
elle a une longévité extraordinaire sur
le trou de l'Angleterre qui en fait
comme je vous le disais le personnage
qui connaît le mieux les rois et
en même temps cette femme a accompagné
les changements d'un siècle
dans l'histoire on n'a jamais vu une
telle accélération des avancées
scientifiques
et cette femme a été contrainte parce
que c'est sa fonction aussi de s'adapter
et si je crois l'adaptabilité de la
monarchie qui qui fait sa force c'est
cette capacité toujours à épouser son
époque ne pas devancer les modes ne pas
être à
contre-temps des de son époque mais a
évolué avec son temps à son rythme voilà
une femme qui envoie des SMS qui a même
des gants qui lui permet de d'aller sur
sur sa tablette numérique qui a été la
première à envoyer un email elle est la
première femme au monde a envoyé un
email puisqu'on lui a présenté le
prototype des des ordinateurs enfin
c'est assez incroyable elle a dû
s'adapter aussi sur le plan des mœurs
elle a autorisé le mariage pour tous et
en donnant un titre on marie de de
Elton John qui lui a demandé si j'étais
marié avec une femme on l'aurait appelé
Lady John qu'est-ce que vous devez à mon
mari donc elle lui a dit il y a un rebel
David fornis oui cette femme elle les
pragmatiques il y a une forme de
pragmatisme à la à la cour d'Angleterre
qui fait que cette femme s'est adaptée à
tout alors parfois et bien elle elle
ravale sa son j'allais dire son amertume
peut-être il y a des peut-être que le
thé parfois est un peu plus amer qui a
des potions qui sont moins faciles à
digérer mais elle a toujours été capable
en tout cas de d'aller avec son temps
d'épouser les les modes elle est devenue
même étrangement une icône de la mode
quand vous voyez le succès qu'elle a
connu avec des livres sur sa garde-robe
elle était iconique
Elisabeth II avait un style inimitable
on pouvait pas la rater c'est d'ailleurs
ce qu'on lui reprochait souvent enfin ce
que les experts modeux lui reprocher
souvent c'est à dire que c'était
ailleurs était quelques jours dans des
camaïeu de couleurs extrêmement criardes
rose bonbon vert anis jaune poussin pas
oublier cette tenue jaune poussin
qu'elle portait pour le mariage de Kate
et William en 2011 cela dit il faut il
faut savoir que ce dress code Royal il
obéissait à des règles extrêmement
strictes la première étant qu'elle
devait être repéré de très loin et avant
tout pour des raisons de sécurité donc
voilà pourquoi elle portait des couleurs
que personne ne portait aussi c'était
pour être repéré de loin
voilà une femme qui avait son effigie
sur les timbres sur les billets de
banque sur les pièces de monnaie la
femme la plus connue au monde et elle
régnait sur un milliard de sujets
elle était ce phare dans la tempête
celle qui défend mordicus les les
traditions
les traditions peuvent évoluer
évidemment mais elle incarnait peut-être
l'institution avec un I majuscule c'est
institution royale qui qu'elle voulait
protéger contre toutes les dérives qu'il
voulait garder conserver comme un
héritage moral qu'elle avait reçu de son
père et qu'elle voulait transmettre au
prince de Galles alors pour cela elle a
accepté beaucoup d'avanie elle a accepté
beaucoup de tourments elle a elle a
supporté beaucoup de de des chemins de
croix la mort de Diana des divorces de
ses enfants la mise en retrait de de son
fils chéri le duc Dior enfin elle a dû
accepter beaucoup de choses mais pour
autant elle a préservé l'essentiel qui
était une certaine manière la mystique
royale je crois qu'elle a eu besoin de
cette mystique royale
pour qu'on continue d'y croire
[Musique]
elle était incroyable elle était on
avait l'impression qu'elle était partout
dans les écoles les crèches les
entreprises
capables d'ouvrir les Jeux Olympiques
capables de faire des speechs devant
tous les dirigeants du monde
venir souvent en France comme pour les
plages du sur les plages du débarquement
tous les anniversaires de du
débarquement de 1944 mais moi ce qui me
ce qui me fascinait c'est qu'elle était
elle allait dans les maisons de retraite
et elle demandait aux gens alors vous
êtes bien et c'est à dire désagréable de
prendre sa retraite pour une femme qui
donne jamais qu'il n'avait même pas idée
de ce que c'était que le mot retraite
[Musique]
n'oubliez jamais une chose elle était
une reine sacrée elle était une sacrée
reine mais une reine sacrée pourquoi
parce qu'elle avait été ouinte par les
saintes huiles par l'archevêque de
Canterbury en l'abbaye de Westminster il
y a plus beaucoup de monarchie sacrales
plus beaucoup de monarchie où on fait du
souverain le lieutenant de Dieu sur
terre
c'était une femme ordinaire placée par
l'histoire et par la tradition donc par
l'hérédité en position extraordinaire
[Musique]
Elisabeth et est devenu reine par
accident en 1952 sans y avoir été
préparé mais auparavant elle était
princesse
héritière sans l'avoir vraiment désirée
en 1952 à la mort de son père contre
prématuré donc elle devient reine elle
apprend cela quand elle est perchée en
haut d'un figuier au Kenya enfin en tout
cas elle est là quand ce produit la mort
prématurée du roi George 6 et c'est un
choc pour elle même si elle s'y était
préparée parce que elle a 25 ans elle
devient reine le prince Philippe devient
prince qu'on sort et ils ont déjà deux
enfants Charles naît en 48 et Anne en
1950 et elle est projetée elle devient
une toute jeune reine
[Musique]
trois personnes vont la guider la reine
Victoria d'abord quel est le pense son
père le roi George VI elle se demande
toujours qu'aurait fait mon père en de
telle circonstances et puis enfin son
premier ministre le premier de ces 14
premiers ministres et c'est Winston
Churchill qui est un peu son mentor et
son guide il lui tient la main en
quelque sorte de toute jeune reine
elle apprend sur le tas évidemment parce
que elle a pas eu le temps de se
préparer aux affaires de l'État donc oui
elle est devenue reine par accident
elle est devenue très vite la femme la
mieux renseignée du pays on raconte que
dans ces jeunes années très vite elle
prend à revers son premier ministre
Winston Churchill en interrogeant sur
des dépêches diplomatiques qui viennent
d'arriver et que lui Apple lui en disant
j'ai rendez-vous avec la reine elle va
passer là-dessus maintenant elle passe
pas là dessus
elle a une longévité extraordinaire sur
le trou de l'Angleterre qui en fait
comme je vous le disais le personnage
qui connaît le mieux les rois et
en même temps cette femme a accompagné
les changements d'un siècle
dans l'histoire on n'a jamais vu une
telle accélération des avancées
scientifiques
et cette femme a été contrainte parce
que c'est sa fonction aussi de s'adapter
et si je crois l'adaptabilité de la
monarchie qui qui fait sa force c'est
cette capacité toujours à épouser son
époque ne pas devancer les modes ne pas
être à
contretemps de son époque mais a évolué
avec son temps à son rythme voilà une
femme qui envoie des SMS qui a même des
gants qui lui permet de d'aller sur sur
sa tablette numérique qui a été la
première à envoyer un email elle est la
première femme au monde a envoyé un
email puisqu'on lui a présenté le
prototype des des ordinateurs enfin
c'est assez assez incroyable elle a dû
s'adapter aussi sur le plan des mœurs
elle a autorisé le mariage pour tous et
en donnant un titre on marie de de
Elton John qui lui a demandé si j'étais
marié avec une femme on l'aurait appelé
Lady John qu'est-ce que vous devez à mon
mari donc elle lui a dit il y a un
rebelle David fornis oui cette femme
elle les pragmatiques il y a une forme
de pragmatisme à la à la cour
d'Angleterre qui fait que cette femme
s'est adaptée à tout alors parfois et
bien elle elle ravale sa son j'allais
dire son amertume peut-être il y a des
peut-être que le thé parfois est un peu
plus amer qui a des potions qui sont
moins faciles à digérer mais elle a
toujours été capable en tout cas de
d'aller avec son temps d'épouser les les
modes elle est devenue même étrangement
une icône de la mode quand vous voyez le
succès qu'elle a connu avec des livres
sur sa garde-robe elle était iconique
Elisabeth II avait un style inimitable
on pouvait pas la rater c'est d'ailleurs
ce qu'on lui reproche souvent face que
les experts modules lui reprocher
souvent c'est à dire que c'était hier
était toujours dans des camaïeu de
couleurs extrêmement criarde
rose bonbon vert anis jaune poussin on
peut pas oublier cette tenue jaune
poussin qu'elle portait pour le mariage
de Kate et William en 2011 cela dit il
faut il faut savoir que ce dress code
Royal il obéissait à des règles
extrêmement strictes la première étant
qu'elle devait être repéré de très loin
et avant tout pour des raisons de
sécurité donc voilà pourquoi elle
portait des couleurs que personne ne
portait aussi c'était pour être repéré
de loin
voilà une femme qui avait son effigie
sur les timbres sur les billets de
banque sur les pièces de monnaie la
femme la plus connue au monde et elle
régnait sur un milliard de sujets
elle était ce phare dans la tempête
celle qui défend mordicus les les
traditions
les traditions peuvent évoluer
évidemment mais elle incarnait peut-être
l'institution avec un I majuscule c'est
institution royale qui qu'elle voulait
protéger contre toutes les dérives qu'il
voulait garder conserver comme un
héritage moral qu'elle avait reçu de son
père et qu'elle voulait transmettre au
prince de Galles alors pour cela elle a
accepté beaucoup d'avanie elle a accepté
beaucoup de tourments elle a elle a
supporté beaucoup de de des chemins de
croix la mort de Diana des divorces de
ses enfants la mise en retrait de de son
fils chéri le duc Dior enfin elle a dû
accepter beaucoup de choses mais pour
autant elle a préservé l'essentiel qui
était une certaine manière la mystique
royale je crois qu'elle a eu besoin de
cette mystique royale
pour qu'on continue d'y croire
[Musique]
et elle était incroyable elle était on
avait l'impression qu'elle était partout
dans les écoles les crèches les
entreprises
capables d'ouvrir les Jeux Olympiques
capables de faire des speechs devant
tous les dirigeants du monde
venir souvent en France comme pour les
plages sur les plages du débarquement
tous les anniversaires de du
débarquement de 1944 mais moi ce qui me
ce qui me fascinait c'est qu'elle était
elle allait dans les maisons de retraite
et elle demandait aux gens alors vous
êtes bien stades agréable de prendre sa
retraite pour une femme qui donne jamais
qui n'avait même pas idée de ce que
c'était que le mot retraite
[Musique]
n'oubliez jamais une chose elle était
une reine sacrée elle était une sacrée
reine mais une reine sacrée pourquoi
parce qu'elle avait été wointe par les
saintes huiles par l'archevêque de canto
Bury en l'abbaye de Westminster il y a
plus beaucoup de monarchie sacrales plus
beaucoup de monarchie où on fait du
souverain le lieutenant de Dieu sur
terre
c'était une femme ordinaire placée par
l'histoire et par la tradition donc par
l'hérédité en position extraordinaire
[Musique]